I just landed a huge deal for you and
then you tell me I'm gonna take five
percent less this year you are
replaceable you see that kind of stuff a
lot that's why Brian Peters wrote you're
in jackass on your parking curb what the
hell man that was one year ago the next
day I started my own company I only have
two employees why is too old and once
too young I've never been on a business
trip before I'm pretty jack can you not
say your whole name today because the
client could lose focus huh I'm like
pancake what was your last name pancake
like breakfast it's Greek it's delicious
yum the good news is we nailed a big
deal and we're traveling to germany to
shake on it hey Dan you gotta be kidding
me this deal may not be done that this
is Chuck Portnoy thing you know don't
you whose pants are so tight is that a
crease no I don't have a priest thank
you split no there's space there is no
space there's actually space it's
alarming you're telling me we're
bankrupt if we don't close this deal
well you're the little guy taking on the
big guy you're gonna go up against me
and dynamic systems we're gonna be hard
to be the first rule is show the client
a good time that's hot snoop lion
probably time to pass that you doing
what happened the second rule how you
doing I'm here for a meeting do not
forget all the other rules
you okay dad I'm not crying that's just
poison in my eyes
if we close this deal I want to make
loved one moment wheelbarrow position
how is it a wheelbarrow one person
spikes is being held up does that feel
good no I mean we should just try to do
it normal maybe put me down wouldn't you
get a chance losing confidence in the
team unfinished business I'm next on the
upgrade list sorry I'd give you my seat
but I've never been upgraded that's all
right I appreciate you it is an honor to
sit in front of you get please I'd like
you to have a seat